Alright, so you've just finished learning how to specify tokens for languages
like HTML and JavaScript.
At this point, you might be thinking, boy, so those HTML and JavaScript designers
did not make pretty tokens.
I just want to mention an experience from my own life. It could be much worse.
I once had the opportunity to work on software that did, let's say, collaborative edits.
Say that a bunch of people wanted to make changes to a book like Pride and Prejudice
by Jane Austin.
Suppose that you really want to make it about pandas instead of people,
and I really want to make Mr. Darcy nicer because he's a bit snappish in the book
as it stands.
In theory, we should be able to apply both of these edits together as long as they
don't conflict and then someone could download that new version of the book
and read it with happy pandas all around.
Because I didn't know much about language design at the time,
I made all of these editing commands very long and very verbose,
including 1 key word token that now lives in infamy for me--
BUTONLYIFITCHANGES--all separated by underscores, 1 word, must be capital letters,
which meant oh, if there's nothing that would change in this scene,
for example, because it doesn't have Mr. Darcy in it,
there's no way to make him happier,
then don't do anything so that people don't think they have to redownload the book
or redownload that chapter.
Because I didn't have any experience with language design,
I made this super long token name, and now I'm stuck with it forever.
You, too, can find it on Google if you search.
So although it may seem now like HTML and JavaScript are totally arbitrary,
in fact, some effort has gone into making them concise and relatively easy.
I just wanted to mention that it could be worse. I know from personal experience.